hello everyone and welcome back to the
finals of the magnus calls in chester we
are in match two and this is the sixth
game of the match so this is the
second game of the blitz section after
four games of rapid the
the end result was a draw as magnus was
able to retaliate in uh
in one of the games uh which is a crazy
one i thought about showing that as well
but i decided to show that one tomorrow
as it uh
would take too much time it's a really
complicated game so i would
prefer to do it with with some more time
on my hands so here
this is the blitz game and it features
something very interesting now the title
of this video
does not refer to the move of the game
that was played but actually to
hikaru's whole approach to the match
which is something that we're going to
discuss
right out of the opening and some of you
are saying that the sound is
uh low uh that you can't uh that you
can't hear
but i've tried the listening to the
video on youtube on my laptop and also
on my phone
uh sounds perfectly perfectly fine i
have no idea why you guys have problems
uh with the sound
but okay getting back to the game
nakamura with the white pieces
opens with e4 and for the two previous
games of the rapid where nakamura had
the white pieces he
went for a line of the berlin defense uh
which is
really weird magnus replies with e5
knight of three knight c6 and bishop to
b5
so the rule lopez is on the board magnus
again goes for the united six line which
is the berlin
and this has already been played twice
in this match in both of the rapid games
and in both of the games nakamura chose
this uh instant
draw uh with castles which goes knight
captures an e4
d4 knight to b6 captures uh
sorry captures on e5 captures on b5 uh
a4
now trapping the knight knight has to go
somewhere so he goes to d4
captures on b4 and now d5 ed6 uh this is
all
very very much known knight captures
queen captures queen captures on d6
and here uh hikaru just played queenie
for check blocks uh queen here
check once again queen blocks and this
is how the game two of the rapids ended
and also how the game four of the rapids
ended so
uh basically i said i'm not gonna play
with white against magnus so he only
played with the black pieces and he won
a brilliant game with black pieces
however in one of the games magnus was
able to retaliate so it was a
very interesting approach to the to the
match like invest all the time preparing
uh
to play with the black pieces and you
know just take a draw with white so it's
definitely interesting however
here in this uh blitz game hikaru does
not castle
uh instead he plays bishop captures on
c6 so here he wants to fight as i guess
he feels more comfortable of fighting
magnus in blitz uh against the berlin
then in rapid
and he also doesn't want to blunder uh
white uh
well to go into armageddon because he
knows that magnus is the one that
chooses the color
since he's the one uh who qualified for
this match via winning a tournament
and therefore magnus would for sure take
the black pieces and he will be would be
forced to play
for a win with the white pieces so
that's why he goes for
a fight here so bishop captures we have
d captures and
now d3 uh we bishop to d6 and then
knight b to d2 so the the meanest of
lines
bishop to g4 and now h3 challenging the
bishop we have bishop
to h5 and now there is one game in the
database where g4 was played
however here we have knight to c4 by
hikaru and it is as a move eight that we
have a completely new game
so here uh hikaru is playing knights the
e3 bring the knight over to f5 played g4
and have that monster knight on f5 and
magnus will
shift his knight over to f8 to then go
to e6 so magnus starts exactly with this
knight d7
and here we have a bit of a horsing
around knight to e3 knight to f8
knight to f5 and knight to e6 both
players improving the position of their
knights
g4 now cementing that knight there on f5
and bishop to g6 and bishop to e3 now
hikaru continues development
c5 magnus grabs hold of the d4 square
and c3 at some point hikaru will of
course have to break through with the d4
we have queen to d7 now preparing the
castle queen side and magnus does the
same
so we have castles queen side castle's
queen side and now
f6 magnus strengthens the at the central
e pawn
uh and now a series of prophylactic
moves king b1
king to b8 and now finally he covers
strikes in the center with
d4 and here uh we have c
captures on b4 so grabbing that pawn in
the center c captures and e
captures on d4 we have knight three
captures on d4
so a nice capture fest uh in the center
not the kind of
capture festival maturing had yesterday
but much much smaller one
knight captures on d4 and now rook
captures on b4
now the bishop cannot move as the queen
is on d7 and he carol plans to bring
this rook over to d1
so bishop captures an f1 the capture
fest continues he captures an f5 and now
h5 magnus wants to open up the h file to
use for his rook
but rook h to d1 and now comes
h captures and g4 with h cap whoa that's
not a captures we have h captures and g4
and the queen to e7 getting the queen
out of the way uh preparing some
trades along the d file bishop is coming
to e5
which will force the trade of rooks and
also the bishop will be on a very
excellent square
however he car stops it for the moment
because now there's a lot of pressure
here so if you're not careful if you try
something like this now
you just get made it captures captures
and just captures
in here and this will be checkmate as
the rook covers the entire d
file so here after queen a4 we have b6
of course magnus needs to
numb down this bishop on e3 and the
queen to c6 by hikaru now
some ideas might be possible here along
along the lda file but it's still very
very far off
so bishop to e5 now offering a trade
here but now he carroll goes to rook to
d7 and okay for the moment the bishop is
guarding the c7 phone but the death
could
change very very quickly for example f4
bishop here rook captures and
all of a sudden you have a lot of
problems so here we have rook captures
and b7
rook captures on b7 and queen to b for
now and here
uh magnus is threatening checkmate uh so
hikaru just blocks it bishop to d4
and not just blocking checkmate but also
preparing to remove the defender of the
c7 square
play captures and checkmate uh one of
the options but now
uh magnus of course needs to block this
he goes bishop to d6
and now hikaru needs to find the move
and it's not all that easy to find a
move
uh because queen to e1 could be very
annoying so here
probably best is bishop e3 you give up
the g for pawn
and if if any checks are are coming your
way you can always just block with the
bishop so here
you you give up a pawn and you try to
survive however hikaru played queen to
e4 here he guards the e1 square
this way but now this simply doesn't
work this completely blunders the game
so feel free to pause the video and win
this game for guitar while i
look for something to show you on my
computer
all right so uh for those of you who
were able to do it congratulations
on spotting the instant win for magnus
and for those of you who just want to
enjoy the show
it's queen to a4 this is what hikaru
missed and the problem is now the rook
is under attack and also the
mate in one is threatened on d1 that's
why bishop to e3
was such a strong move in that position
and here when hiharu saw this
he immediately made this face there we
can check it out
one more time not one more time for the
first time there you have it
uh quite a quite an odd thing for for
hikaru
the blunder such a puzzle rush expert to
miss something like this but
what are you going to do happens to
everyone he he made very very few
mistakes
since this entire match started and this
is definitely his biggest one yet
so yeah after queen to a4 of course
hikaru immediately resigns because you
have to prevent the checkmate by
something like this you give up a whole
rook and then it's
just pointless to continue so magnus
clinch is a win and with this the match
so he equalizes
one to one in matches and we will now
have uh match three
with the the score being leveled so it
was a really really incredible stuff
like i said i will show you the game
that magnus won in the rapids but i will
do that tomorrow
as it's really a complicated one but
here like i said uh really
uh you know i don't think i've ever seen
this strategy i don't know if that was
the strategy or maybe it was just a spur
of the moment thing for hikaru to
uh force that draw with white in both of
the games of the rapid
however it is very interesting you know
you know you have a draw with white so
why not spend all of your time preparing
for
uh you know just winning with the black
pieces and he almost pulled it off
if that was his plan but in the end uh
magnus prevailed
with with hikaru blundering this uh this
idea
uh but yeah it would be hard even if
this game ended in a draw magnus would
choose black in armageddon and it's uh
well it's hard to imagine that
you you can win against magnus on demand
uh
it's very very hard to imagine but
anything can happen as it always does in
chess
so that's uh the game i do hope you
enjoyed it i'm sure he car
most certainly didn't uh and uh let's
just check this out one more time there
you go
uh sad hikaru uh so yeah
uh once again uh i hope you i do hope
you enjoyed it uh i would like to thank
james cole
uh keith waterman stefan gebbart uh
mandy gaushal and brian powell for a
contribution to my channel
thank you a lot i really appreciate it
as usual uh you can check two of my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the magnus uh
chester finals checking up on your
wonderful suggestions
and whatever else happens in the chess
world so thank you all i will see you
soon and have an excellent rest of your
day
and meadow also says hi say hello
nope no he doesn't see soon